roux et eric emmanuel schmitt frédéric
salat-baroux ancien secrétaire général
de l'elysée au temps de jacques chirac a
écrit un livre consacré à la relation
entre de gaulle et pétain une réflexion
sur ce formidable roman français eric
emmanuel schmitt a écrit un livre
intitulé quand je pense que beethoven
est mort et que tendent un piège
addiction une pièce qui manquait au cou
l'un et l'autre texte tourne autour de
l'oeuvre musicale de better jean marie
colombani nous invite à prendre le temps
de la réflexion
ce soir à 23h sur public sénat bonjour à
tous suite ce matin du projet de loi sur
la réforme des retraites
les joutes verbales se poursuivent dans
l'hémicycle et les sénateurs de
l'opposition continue à discuter le
texte pied à pied hier trente deux
amendements ont été discutés il en reste
encore deux cent soixante a examiné hier
soir les discussions ont repris à
l'article 32 sur la question de
l'épargné retraite
la nuit a aussi été marquée par le vote
par les sénateurs d'un amendement de la
majorité qui prévoit l'ouverture de la
réflexion pour 2013 vers une retraite
par points c'est-à-dire d'art une
réforme systémique
l'amendement a été taxé de manoeuvre par
l'opposition dans une ambiance
surchauffée
c'était un geste en faire la cfdt qui
faisait cette demande
l'intersyndicale en tout cas se réunit
cet après midi pour décider des suites à
donner au mouvement
la situation est un peu compliquée entre
l'arrivée des vacances de la toussaint
puis le vote imminent de la réforme par
les sénateurs une septième journée de
mobilisation pourrait être organisée la
semaine prochaine mardi ou mercredi
tout de suite direction les débats
d'hier soir dans l'hémicycle
la séance est reprise
j'informe le sénat que la commission
mixte paritaire chargée de proposer un
texte sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi organique
relatif à la gestion de la dette sociale
est parvenu à l'adoption d'un texte
commun
nous reprenons donc la discussion du
projet de loi 2 puis par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée portant réforme des
retraites dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus au vote
sur l'amendement numéro 7 153 au sein de
l'article 30 de cette pièce madame
demontès a demandé la parole monsieur
fisher mais c'est le président vous avez
la parole oui même la présidente
c'est un petit rappel au règlement en
fille en guise de sourire tout au cours
de ces journées et plus particulièrement
de cette journée guillaume sarkozy a été
omniprésent dans nos débats dans nos
débats
et quelle ne fut pas ma surprise après
la réforme des retraites
eh bien quelle ne fut pas ma surprise de
trouver le rappel d'une invitation
et qu'est ce que je lis monsieur le vice
président nous organisons un prochain
déjeuner de travail auquel nous vous
avons convié sur le thème
alors voyez alors qu'elle sera
l'assurance maladie de demain alors vous
voyez et autour de qui devinez et bien
au tour de guillaume sarkozy
voilà voyez que c'est un homme qui a
toujours une longueur d'avancé et qui
est omniprésent et je rappelle que
guillaume sarkozy est le délégué général
de malakoff médéric et il organisera ce
nom il organisera ce prochain déjeuner
de travail avec paul grasset directeur
général du groupe pro btp d'employés si
on veut avoir une idée et puis là j'ai
trouvé ça aussi là il n'y a pas de
raison d'avoir peur de la retraite
complémentaire privée
bon ça c'est la suite voilà excuses et
madame la présidente
bien sûr le président bon dans la vie
dont monsieur frimas rien ces
interventions de président de commission
affaires sociales
juste avant la suspension de séance qui
m'amène à vous demander des précisions
présidente pour que nous sachions
exactement comment nous allons
travailler si j'ai bien compris ma
présidente
vous avez demandé la priorité pour faire
revenir quelques articles additionnels
qui était en réserve et les faire
revenir en priorité alors pourrait-on
savoir devenir très exact
à quel moment vous êtes les faire venir
est ce que votre priorité s'applique
immédiatement après l'article qui est en
discussion est-ce qu'elle s'applique
après le 33 elle a peut-être dit
monsieur le président à vous même c'est
que j'ai toujours beaucoup de difficulté
à comprendre les choses
donc j'ai besoin qu'on les précise avec
la gentillesse qui vous est coutumière
de ce président donc si vous pouviez
nous préciser de façon à ce que je
dirais l'ensemble de mes collègues
je dirais ont compris qu'ils avaient la
priorité mais ont pas compris de manière
très précise à quel moment s'intercaler
votre priorité
nous ne discutons pas la priorité va
nommer présidente puisque à partir du
moment où la présidente de commission
demande la priorité avec l'accord du
gouvernement celle ci est de droit donc
nous ne discutons pas mais nous voulons
simplement savoir très précisément à
quel endroit vite excède s'applique
merci c'est demandé j'ai demandé cette
priorité après l'article 33 et au début
des articles additionnels sur les sur
les crêtes article additionnel
cette précision merci je vous rappelle
donc dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus au vote sur
l'amendement numéro 7 153 au sein de
l'article 32
donc avant de faire voter sur cet
amendement 753 y at il des explications
de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets aux voix je
mets au voir là monsieur emorine
saisie d'un public
je
arrêté
monsieur le président fischer vous
voulez un peu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
parce que n'a pas bien entendu sur quoi
portait le scrutin public 5 753 700 ce
je suis donc saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe ump sur
l'amendement 753 de monsieur fisher je
vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable ainsi que
l'avis du gouvernement il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront aux cinquante et un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre 1
but en bleu et ceux qui souhaitent
obtenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
et
non
en
le scrutin est ouvert
et voilà
les tables
on
alors
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
j'invite mesdames et messieurs les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
passe
comment
bonjour
là
or
on est mort
ça y est
mais
là
il
la gr
une erreur mais il a fait feu
j'ai voté
d'accord
là
à deux pas
enfin
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 72
sur sur l'amendement numéro 7 153 à
l'article 30 de cette pièce ça si vous
êtes intéressé par le résultat joue
serais reconnaissant de vous asseoir et
de faire un peu de silence merci nombre
de votants 337 nombre de suffrages
exprimés 336 majorité absolue des
suffrages exprimés et 169 pour
l'adoption 153 contre 183 le sénat n'a
pas adopté sur l'amendement 477 je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe ump sur l'amendement 477
qui a été présenté par madame demontès
monsieur teulade si j'ai bien souvenir
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission défavorable à cycle a commis
la vie du gouvernement il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront aux secrétaires un bulletin
blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
bleus ceux qui souhaitent obtenir
un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
je
on
le scrutin est ouvert
oui
je plains
qui
là
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
j'invite une amie secrétaire a procédé
au dépouillement du scrutin
en cours
alors
je
com
parti
non
voici le résultat
voici le résultat du scrutin 73
l'amendement numéro 477 à l'article 32
70 s nombre de votes en 339 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 338 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 170 pour
l'adoption 153 contre 185
le sénat n'a pas adopté
nous poursuivons s'il vous plaît nous
poursuivons s'il vous plaît alors je
vais vers voter sur l'article 30 de ses
pièces y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
il n'y en a pas je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
ump sur la l'ensemble de l'article 30 de
chaque pièce je vous rappelle que la
commission est favorable ainsi que
l'avis du gouvernement
bon ben on écoutait ce qui est non
excusez nous mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'on soit un petit peu qu'on présente
un peu de calme pendant ce pour cette
soirée
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront sur un terrain
bulletins blancs ceux qui souhaitent
voter contre un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
vivre
pendant que les autres
la pro d2
le scrutin est ouvert
c'est
il
non
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
j'invite monsieur le secrétaire a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
une fois
c'est un fait
la france
pire encore
quoi
alors
voici le résultat du scrutin 74
article 32 cette pièce du projet de loi
portant réforme des retraites nombre de
votes en 337 nombre de suffrages
exprimés et 336 majorité absolue des
suffrages exprimés 869 pour l'adoption
183 contre 153 le sénat a adopté
une demande de parole mesurables et
madame la présidente
la fois en tant que porte parole de mon
groupe sur la situation de maintenant et
en tant que secrétaire de séance
je vous demande madame la présidente
conte de vérifier qu'on puisse continuer
dans des conditions raisonnables c'est
pas possible je mesure à l'heure
actuelle l'attachement que le groupe ump
à ce projet de loi en tous les cas par
leur présence physique autrement dit
vite ils votent avec leurs pieds
alors nous nous
excusez moi de vous dire que je vous
trouve un peu agité ce soir m'enfin
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé pendant le
dîner mais trouve agitée est ce que
c'est un rappel au règlement
alors allez-y
non
je ne sais pas qui est agitée mais nous
on veut pouvoir travailler normalement
on avait
on veut travailler normalement et nous
commençons une reprise de séance sans
savoir exactement quand elle finira et
certains s'en foutent peut-être mais il
y en a d'autres qui ont fait plusieurs
nuits et qui veulent un peu savoir où va
mais nous sommes prêts à aller au bout
du bout parce que nous sommes en santé
motivées
deuxièmement deuxièmement nous apprenons
que l'elysée monsieur guéant sommes
écoutés
je vais vous dire une chose et ça c'est
indépendant de la gauche ou de la droite
je vous le dis très sincèrement quand je
suis arrivé dans cet hémicycle en 2004
il était inconcevable inconcevable que
ce soit qu'une affaire de gauche et
droite le fait qu'on puisse de l'elysée
directement dire comment doit travailler
le caylar dante à tout moment il y
aurait eu quelqu'un dans vos rangs qui
se serait levée qui aurait dit je n'ai
jamais vu ça alors je le dis pourquoi
parce qu' il faudrait pas que quand dans
d'autres domaines
il y accoutumance pas d'accoutumance et
il se trouve que quand monsieur guéant
fait ça ce qui est un scandale absolu
auquel on ne doit pas s'habituer
et bien c'est c'est le groupe c le
groupe ump
c'est c'est ce qu'a dit mon collègue à
eau
il a il a dit il a dit que ce n'est pas
possible que dans cette situation où on
accepte ce type de chose en plus et le
groupe ump qui ralentit la séance on
assure en même pas sa présence dans
l'hémicycle
voilà donc je voulais dire madame la
présidente qu' on ne pouvait pas quand
même parce que c'est pas fait couramment
rabroué de cette façon notre collègue
parce qu'il a dit cette simple chose
comme une attitude agitée voilà c'était
une intervention tout à fait respectable
et qui avait sa place
monsieur le ministre j'ai juste à vous
monsieur sénateur je vois pas ce qu'il
ya de choquant dans les propos de
monsieur guéant les sénateurs commandes
beaucoup ce que fait l'elysée
je vois pas si ça en quoi c'est choquant
que l'elysée a un moment donné commente
mais comment donne une opinion le chacun
a le droit de dire un peu ce qu'il veut
donne une opinion sans influencer ou
sans influer sur les travaux du sénat
donc c'est une opinion elle est prise
comme telle mais je remarque que le
sénat commente beaucoup beaucoup c'est
ce que fait l'elysée
merci monsieur le ministre alors nous
nous sommes nous sommes sur l'article 32
pièces et nous allons étudier
l'amendement 54 que présente madame
beaufils vous avez la parole même beau
fils merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre et chers collègues je
voudrais quand même dire que je
j'aimerais moi aussi avoir une réponse
sur les horaires qui vont être les
nôtres ce soir et éventuellement cette
nuit quand même ça serait intéressant
mais je vais venir leur à l'amendement
54 peut-être que à l'occasion d'une
réponse à cet amendement nous aurons une
réponse aussi sur l'organisation de nos
travaux avec cet article 32 aux pièces
nous arrivons au terme de la discussion
sur l'ensemble des amendements que les
députés à l'assemblée nationale ont
décidé de mettre au coeur de cette
réforme députés de la majorité excusez
moi j'aurais dû dire donc que les
députés ont décidé de mettre au coeur de
cette réforme le développement des
différentes formes de capitalisation qui
ont un seul objectif mettre à bas notre
système solidaire en créant le titre 5
bis relatif à l'épargne-retraite
juste avant les dispositions finales de
ce projet de loi
c'est donc en quelque sorte un bouquet
final destructeur de notre système par
péréquation que les députés ont choisi
pour terminer ce texte
aux termes de ce projet ils ont tenu à
mettre en place tout un psy
thème de possibilités de contraintes
forçant la mise en place de comptes
épargne retraite pour créer les
conditions d'une individualisation à
venir alors que chacun reconnaît que
notre système de retraite est confronté
à un problème de financement et que les
finances publiques sont au plus mal
l'ensemble des mesures ici préconisé
vont une nouvelle fois contribué à vider
les caisses de nouvelles ressources sont
défiscalisées exempté de cotisations
sociales
de ce fait elles seront aussi soustraite
aux cotisations retraite
plus précisément cet article 32 aux
pièces vise à réécrire l'article 163
quater vis yes du code général des
impôts qui prévoit la déductibilité du
revenu net global soumis à l'impôt sur
le revenu des cotisations et des primes
versées au profit d'un compte épargne
retraite
cette mesure vise plus précisément à
rendre plus attractifs fiscalement les
contrats épargne obligatoire mis en
place par les employeurs aussi
connaissant notre position à ce type de
contrat départ vous ne serez pas étonné
que vous nous vous demandions la
suppression de cet article mais ce qui
me surprend le plus c'est que vous
essayez vous ayez accepté de mettre dans
un texte quelque chose qui aggravent
notre situation fiscale au moment où
dole
vous nous dites que vous allez faire en
sorte de réduire les niches fiscales
dans la prochaine loi de finances il ya
quand même des contradictions qu'il est
bon de souligner au moment où on débat
des questions de retraite alors que nous
allons le voir probablement plus tard
nous avons nous des propositions qui
n'ont rien à voir avec de la
fiscalisation merci l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable madame la présence vis du
gouvernement
je mets au voile amendement numéro 56 64
que sont ceux qui sont favorables
vous madame office une explication de
vote
oui pour une explication de vote mais
surtout pour une remarque que je pensais
que le fait qu'on ait soulevé cette
question de la fiscalisation aurait
amené quand même une réaction
gouvernementale pas d'autres
explications de jeu mais aux voix cet
amendement ceux qui sont favorables à
son adoption voudront bien levé la main
ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adopté l'article 32 e pièce
y at il des explications de vote sur cet
article
je n'en vois pas ce qu'ils sont
favorables à son adoption lèveront la
main ceux qui sont contre il est adopté
l'article 33 avec une demande de parole
de monsieur david assouline
il n'est pas là monsieur de mais elle
n'est pas là monsieur maurouard
désir
je suis
monsieur bré disent que vous avez la
parole madame la présidente monsieur
ministre mesdames messieurs sénateurs
j'interviens au lendemain de la sixième
journée d'action organisée par les
syndicats
parler des lycéens par des groupes de
différentes natures et par un conflit
qui manifestement s'élargit et poses
très gros problèmes à la nation et à la
population
on nous dit que monsieur sarkozy veut
essayer de trouver la sortie
ce n'est pas en force qu'il faut essayer
de trouver la sortie
c'est naturellement en faisant des
propositions puissent y aller dans le
sens dans le sens finalement d'une
réunion d'une discussion d'une
négociation et c'est toujours possible
pour arriver nulle pa
finalement au but c'est à dire une
retraite qui donne satisfaction aux
français et aux françaises
alors je suis intervenu vendredi
monsieur le ministre cette occasion là
vous avez fait de l'ironie
vous avez dit que moi même et pas
seulement moi même et sénateurs
socialistes c'est que la gauche disait
mais les chiffres ronds propose que ça à
voir les chiffres on va avec le débat
pas qui est le nôtre
moi je ne suis pas banquier je suis
revenu pad et vias d'argent et cetera
je ne sais pas ce que c'est que les
chiffres ronds par rapport aux autres
chiffres
et j'avoue d'ailleurs que les chiffres
de victoire de la gauche sont pas
nécessairement des chiffres ronds à 48
c'est pas un site rrêt 71 1871 est pas
un chiffre rond 36 quand on n'a
peut-être pas suffisamment parler et pas
un chiffre rond et pas davantage
d'offres chif
enfin passons sur ça alors le vrai
problème qui est discuté de josé et je
vais discuter ne pas la dernière fois de
la retraite à 60 ans alors je pas y
revenir simplement puisqu'on a parlé de
chiffres ronds comme ça aide mon amour
pour ces chiffres ronds et peut-être
pour ma nostalgie pour retraite à 60 ans
pas je dois dire que tout de même dieu
une résonance dans pays vous avez pu en
trouver l'écho dans la revue de presque
sont certainement vos collaborateurs
moi j'en ai entendu beaucoup parler noir
je suis rentrée à lille s'est vu quand
même comment tout le monde veut réussir
à capter pas ce message qu'au fond tout
le monde restait attaché à la retraite à
60 ans et que ce n'était pas possible de
rejeter ces trois êtres 60 ans dans les
oubliettes de la république ça ce n'est
pas possible
par conséquent pour le prendre en
considération ensuite problème de la
réforme a en réformes la forme
nous nous sommes attachés à la réforme
de temps en temps mais m'ont dit que
nous sommes des réformistes à ce sont
vous devrait
enfin nous sommes attachés à la réforme
attaché à la réforme alors monsieur
sarkozy se dit attaché aussi à la
réforme
oui mais il ya de bonnes réformes et il
ya de mauvaises et de très mauvaises
réformes
par conséquent il faut rester dans le
registre des bonnes réformes celles qui
plaisent aux peuples celles qui plaisent
à majorité des français et des
françaises est manifestement la réforme
que nous proposons nous sommes pas les
seuls eh bien elle va dans le bon sens
et il ne faut pas par conséquent
l'oublier j'ajoute que chemin faisant on
discute un peu d'ensemble de tous les
problèmes
on laisse beaucoup de problèmes sur le
côté mais c'est vrai qu'on aura
peut-être l'occasion de les reprendre
en tout cas la retraite à 60 ans c'est
pas possible qu'elle aggrave la
situation des jeunes pas possible
qu'elle aggrave la situation des seniors
c'est quand même un comble dit un peu
que ces seniors les uns les met à la
porte de plus en plus rapidement et par
conséquent de plus en plus jeune et que
l'on fasse une réforme pour finalement
leur fermer la porte pour accéder non
pas à la retraite
ça c'est vraiment inimaginable et je
suis persuadé qu'ils garderont le
souvenir ça rend définitive
je sais bien vous pouvez bomber le torse
pouvez vous dire mon à la majorité ici
ai pas pensé quand on sort sortira avec
la majorité
oui mais cette majorité elle sera
relative parce que il y aura un autre
appel ce sera appel devant le peuple et
cette fois là ce sera la grande élection
qui tranchera alors sur le problème en
particulier de la retraite et sur bien
d'autres problèmes et je suis persuadé
que sur ce plan là vous marquez de
mauvais points vis-à-vis du peuple par
les positions qui sont les vôtres
en tous les cas tous les sondages moi je
n'abuse pas des sondages mais montre que
la grande majorité des français et des
françaises seules
à plus de 50 % à plus de 60% ce matin
c'était 65%
il a pris son contre la réforme que vous
envisagez et ça vous devez en tenir
compte
alors le gouvernement finalement se
positionne donc se réfugie dans une
position de faiblesse qui sera jugé par
le peuple
au delà même des péripéties des votes
dans cette assemblée
mais les votes dans cet ensemble ils ont
leur importance
le sénat on connaît la réputation qu'il
a eu sur la troisième république
on connaît la réputation qu'il a eu sous
la quatrième république qui en avait
fait un sénat croupion on connais toi la
réputation qu'il avait au début de la
vème république
en voulant véritablement faire une
réforme du sénat
méfiez-vous le sénat ne pas ne doit pas
redevenir la chambre noire de la
république à il doit au contraire côté
des propositions des réformes
ils ont attendu par le peuple et prend
des dispositions pour qu'il en soit
ainsi
faute de quoi vous aurez des lendemains
difficiles comme vos prédécesseurs
sénateurs pardon
qu'est ce que vous me dites pas d'âme
je commence à peine le chacun peut être
que le dvd de vider merci de bien
vouloir terminer votre intervention s'il
vous plaît monsieur le premier ministre
vous accordez combien la terminer parce
que vous avez dépassé
vous avez dépassé votre temps de parole
ou vieux m'avertir madame bon je veux
quand même apporter une conclusion mme
oda qui s il vous plaît si vous ma
conclusion c'est qu'il ya deux problèmes
fondamentaux
le premier c'est naturellement la durée
on voit combien de il faudra d'annuités
pour la retraite
sur ce plan là mais c'est pas une mesure
tellement social mesures sociales mais
elle dépasse sociale c'est une mesure de
civilisation la vie s'allonge faut par
conséquent en tirer les conséquences y
compris sur le plan pas des retraites et
je pense que la première secrétaire du
parti socialiste s'est exprimé sur cette
question mais laissez-moi terminé le
seul à terminer je vous en prie vous par
écoutez je vous le dirai ça c'est la
première première chose oui on veut je
sais bien vous faites le chahut
j'étais habitué à toutes les mesures
sociales que j'ai présentées alors que
j'étais premier ministre j'avais la
droite
vent debout ça vous a oublié de le
rappeler mais nous le savons et nous
pensons je devais dire écoutez pour par
français comptent tenir compte de cette
donne et de la durée mais tenir compte
de la durée
cette nuit je termine merci monsieur
biminis non m'adresse ici aussi tenir
compte de l'assiette ne sait ce n'est
pas les salariés seuls qui peuvent payer
ces retraites faut par conséquent
l'élargir et l'élargir sans doute au
capital j'avais des propositions à vous
faire sur ce plan là voilà je vous dis
que si vous ne prenez pas une mesure que
le peuple attend il y aura des
conséquences qui seront redoutables et
bien ne prenons pas ce chemin il ya un
chemin pour temps qui permettrait
d'accorder à chacun une retraite
convenable et bien ces propositions que
nous faisons
je vous remercie
kyi qui défend l'amendement 1156
merci madame la présidente a lors de la
discussion sur l'article 3 nous avons
indiqué les réticences que nous
nourrissions à l'égard des dispositions
introduites mais également les avancées
de ce droit à l'information
en effet l'article 3 vise à renforcer
l'information dispensée aux assurés en
matière de retraite d'une part en
prévoyant de leur fournir une
information générale sur le système de
retraite dès leur première acquisition
de droits et d'autre part en créant un
entretien personnalisé à partir de l'âge
de 45 ans pourtant à l'article 33 la
mise en oeuvre de cette obligation est
différé ainsi le présent alinéa de cet
article prévoit une entrée en vigueur de
cette disposition
repoussé par la haine le 1er janvier au
1er janvier 2011 au 31 décembre 2012
pour notre part nous considérons que le
telle disposition qui améliore le droit
à l'information des assurés sociaux sur
les différents régimes de retraite
doivent entrer en vigueur de suite le
droit d'information est institué par la
loi de 2003 qui prévoit la fourniture
automatique tous les cinq ans à partir
de 35 ans dans relevé de situation
individuelle et à partir de 55 ans d'une
estimation indicative globale du montant
de la pension et cette mission jusqu'à
présent assurées par le gip info
retraite et dans ce cadre de l'article 3
cela représente certes une avancée en
permettant aux salariés de disposer de
ces informations plutôt pourtant et sur
le fond nous craignons que de ce point
d'étape retraite ceux de soi utilisées
non seulement pour informer les assurés
mais aussi pour promouvoir la
souscription de produits financiers et
donc la retraite par capitalisation
en effet comme nous vous le rappelions
dans la discussion à cet article 3 et
selon l'étude d'impact accompagnant ce
projet de loi et les prévu 2,7 que cet
entretien portera notamment sur les
avantages respectifs des différents
dispositifs d'incitation à la
prolongation d'activité ainsi que les
sur les dispositifs leur permettant
d'améliorer
le montant de leur future retraite le
point étape retraite donc à 45 ans
risque malheureusement de se transformer
en une information orienté pour ne pas
dire une incitation systématique à
recourir au plan d'épargne-retraite donc
bien que nous soyons attaché à ce droit
à l'information nous demandant cependant
la suppression de cet alinéa qui
repousse son entrée en vigueur
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur défavorable madame la
présidente
l'avis du gouvernement mais ma vie je
vais faire voter sur cet amendement 1156
qui à recueillir l'avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont favorables à
son adoption
ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adopté trois amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro deux cent quarante
et une que présente madame demontès à 1
c'est cet amendement ficfa cet article
fixe les conditions d'entrée en vigueur
de plusieurs dispositions du projet de
loi fixe la mais l'amélioration du droit
à l'information des assurés
là nous n'avons pas grand chose à dire
mais là où ça se gâte c'est les articles
5 à 20 l'article 22 25 et 30 puisque
c'est l'entrée en vigueur de mesures que
nous rejetons en bloc
c'est à dire les conditions d'entrée en
vigueur du passage de 60 à 62 ans et la
borne de 65 à 67 ans
c'est globalement une politique barbare
nous contestons le bien fondé de cette
réforme d'un point de vue global car
cela ne répond pas aux réels enjeux de
la question des retraites
vous vous placez sur le terrain de la
démographie quand c'est d'orientation
économique il conviendrait de discuter
le recul de l'âge pour obtenir sa
retraite à taux plein quand on n'atteint
pas le nombre d'annuités requises
pourrait prétendre avant est l'exemple
même du caractère idéologique et
inhumain du texte qui sont les personnes
qui ne pourront satisfaire à ce nombre
d'annuités principalement les femmes et
nous vous le dirons et les personnes
ayant une carrière une carrière
mouvementée h&h et nous croyons pour
notre part qu'il s'agit de personnes
fragiles précaires
ayant connu une vie difficile à 65 ans
bien des gens ont été effectués une
carrière complète ou quasi complète à
court terme
la grande majorité si ce n'est
l'ensemble des français qui atteindront
l'âge de 65 ans au cotiser le temps
requis à l'exception je le dis encore
des femmes qui jongle avec les temps
partiels le plus souvent subi les
périodes de chômage d'inactivité et les
personnes ayant eu des carrières brisées
earth est inhabituel pour nous le mot
réforme est synonyme de progrès quand un
texte qui se veut réformateur
fragilisent encore des catégories
précaire il se pare d'atours qu'ils ne
méritent pas nous sommes résolument
opposés au recul de l'âge de la retraite
à 62 ans et la retraite à taux plein à
67 ans
si certains veulent travailler plus la
loi les autorise à le faire mais que ce
que ceux qui veulent s'arrêter parce que
la vie ne l'aura pas
déjà fait beaucoup de cadeaux puisse le
faire voilà ce qui me semble un réel
progrès la solidarité doit avoir un sens
dans notre pays
parcourir par cohérence avec tout ce que
nous avons dit nous demandant la
suppression de l'alinéa qui fixe les
conditions en vigueur des dispositions
de ce texte qui est loin de marquer un
progrès de société qui est acceptable
par non merci
l'amendement 1157 c'est madame david
qu'il présente ou monsieur fisher 1157
madame la présidente a présenté
il s'agit d'un amendement de pure forme
mais symbolique
nous vous proposons ainsi de supprimer
dans cet alinéa l'article 33 les
références aux articles 26 27 quater et
27 une pièce pour la simple et bonne
raison que ces amendements ont été
supprimés lors du passage en commission
cela démontre alors que le sujet est
tout de même sérieux puisqu'il a trait
aux conditions d'existence des plus de
60 ans de leur pouvoir d'achat que de
leurs droits à la retraite de la
précipitation dont vous faites preuve
sur ce sujet mais cela démontre
également la confusion qui a régné lors
des travaux de la commission des
affaires sociales afin d'élaborer le
texte dont nous sommes en train de
débattre pour simple rappel les articles
ainsi supprimé concerné l'abaissement de
la condition d'âge pour le départ à la
retraite et le bénéfice du taux plein au
profit des assurés justifiant d'une
incapacité permanente au titre d'une
maladie ou d'un accident professionnel
il concernait également l'extension du
dispositif de pénibilité aux salariés
agricoles et non agricoles
la commission a fait le choix de
supprimer ces articles insérez lors de
l'examen du texte lan pour en situer le
contenu dans d'autres articles du texte
il faut maintenant que le présent
article en tiennent compte c'est le sens
de cet amendement
merci l'amendement 1213 monsieur leclerc
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales oui madame la présidente c'est
juste un amendement de coordination
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre la commission pardon la
commission sur l'amendement 241 et 11
157 ils sont est favorable tous les deux
excusez moi madame et l'avis du
gouvernement tous sens sur les trois
amendements et l'avis du gouvernement
sur les trois amendements
je mets donc aux voix l'amendement 240p
une madame david a demandé la parole
pour une explication de vote
oui une explication de vote qui sera
très courte mes chers collègues mais
sincèrement l'avis défavorable du
rapporteur et du ministre sur notre
amendement me semble quand même tout à
fait étrange puisque nous demandons ni
plus ni moins de supprimer les alinéas
que va supprimer le rapporteur dans son
ami sans son propre amendement
donc si vous regardez bien les deux nous
n'en supprimions que 3 vous en supprimer
un peu plus mais ce que nous proposions
de supprimer son ce que vous allez
supprimer vous même monsieur le
rapporteur donc j'aimerais simplement
vous faire remarquer que là pour le coup
vos réponses ne sont quand même pas à la
hauteur du travail que l'on a pu fournir
pendant ce débat et ne sont pas
respectueux non plus de ce que l'on peut
vous proposer à partir du moment où ce
sont des amendements de notre groupe
ils sont je trouve un peu traitée à la
va vite
monsieur le rapporteur et je le regrette
je le regrette car nous avons fait un
travail il me semble qu'ils ne vous
convient pas évidement qui ne vous
convient pas évidement pas ce que nous
proposons un autre système
une autre réforme pour notre système de
retraite par répartition mais quand même
un minimum de respect pour le travail
que nous pouvons faire nous mêmes et et
nos collaborateurs aussi qu'ils ont
beaucoup travaillé pendant ces trois
semaines
monsieur le rapporteur merci madame la
présidente je n'admets pas les propos
qui sont tenus à mon égard je m'excuse
madame david vous me connaissez vous
savez que je n'agis pas comme ça j'étais
et c'est vrai en train de regarder un
amendement à venir et je n'ai pas vu les
votants le votre arrivée alors je vous
en prie un peu de respect ça ne fera pas
de mal la seule chose que je puisse dire
non non non non
chers collègues on se connaît trop pour
que nous sachions aussi restée en dedans
de certains propos donc dans
l'amendement de la commission que je
porte
j'ai me remplacer les références par
d'autres références qui sont dans
l'énoncé demande de mon amendement le
vôtre vous contentez de supprimer les
références voilà il ya quand même un
petit distinguo je m'excuse de ne pas
l'avoir dit au moment venu mais je
regardais un autre amendement donc
soyons calme monsieur mahias madame la
présidente sur les ministres chers
collègues vous venez monsieur le
rapporteur de nous parler de respect
j'ai entendu ce mot et je voudrais quand
même vous rappeler que respecter ce
texte cette loi c'est avant tout avoir
discuté avec les organisations
syndicales
ça vous gêne les organisations
syndicales d'autant qu'en ce moment
effectivement elles sont dans la rue et
elle montre au peuple de france que ce
texte est effectivement mauvais
peut-être aurait-il plus intelligent
pour respecter cette démocratie
d'intervenir bien en amont de faire
comme beaucoup de pays l'ont fait parce
que on souhaite par exemple ces
discussions a duré des mois et des mois
et et et j'ai je suis moi même intervenu
pour vous dire que nous nous sommes
conscients qu'il faille une réforme des
retraites
nous en sommes les uns et les autres
conscient mais une bonne réforme
comme disait pierre mauroy une bonne
réforme
à nice par tous et qu'il n'y ait pas des
gens brimés par rapport à des gens
favorisés alors par exemple cette amende
en cet amendement c'est l'exemple même
de gens qui sont tout à fait brimer les
dispositions d'entrée en vigueur
on pouvait les étals et beaucoup plus
j'avais donné cet exemple de quelqu'un
d'une jeune femme d'une femme commençant
à 14 ans qui certes grâce à une petite
adaptation pouvait espérer partir en
retraite à 58 ans oui mais au bout du
compte elle aura cotisé quarante quatre
ans c'est à dire plus que le maximum
exigé et en règle générale ces métiers
là sont des métiers durs parce que ce
sont des métiers qui n'exige pas une
grande qualification donc le côté études
est extrêmement restreint et donc vous
pénalisez deux fois souvent des métiers
pénibles en plus pénible est donc vous
pénalisez plusieurs fois comme vous le
faites d'ailleurs pour pour aussi le
passage de 65 à 67 ans par il vous a été
dit et répété que souvent les femmes les
femmes avec des carrières plus haché
avec des difficultés particulières se
trouve encore plus pénalisées
donc vous n'avez pas l'habitude
d'ailleurs je dois le dire de laisser
des laps de laps de temps suffisant pour
que humainement les gens puissent
réfléchir nous je l' ai vu lorsque nous
avons défendu disons le les infirmières
pour leur donner le choix de passer
d'une catégorie b à une catégorie à
le laps de temps et est ridicule et on
est actuellement vous il est envoyé à
ces personnes des missives en or
demandant d'une façon impérative de
choisir est je voudrais terminer sur le
problème des fonctionnaires lorsque vous
rentrez effectivement dans la fonction
publique c'est un choix
c'est un choix vous en connaissez la
grandeur vous en connaissez les
difficultés et vous en connaissez les
avantages et bien très simplement là
vous rognez vous renier sur les
avantages il y à une rupture de contrat
il y a un engagement normale entre
l'état d'une part et le fonctionnaire le
fonctionnaire doit effectivement l'état
rendre à la fois du travail bien fait et
un certain laps de temps de travail un
certain nombre d'années de travail et
vous évoluez à banon déjà supprimer un
fonctionnaire sur deux partant en
retraite oui c'est une chose déjà qui
peut très bien
fortement déplaire et fortement
pénalisés en ce moment les gens qui sont
dans l'enseignement un des remplacements
sont plus assurées par exemple mais en
plus il ya une rupture de contrat
donc quand il y à ce type de difficultés
on étale dans le temps et tout était là
étalé dans le temps
les discussions sont étalés dans le
temps les mises en oeuvre des mesures
doivent être étalés dans le temps c'est
pas ce que vous faites
il y a le couperet qui tombe et moi je
défends effectivement avec le groupe
socialiste damon merci s'il n'y a pas
d'autres explications de vote
il n'y a pas besoin de n'ai pas besoin
et
sur le 241 je suis saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public sur la moment 241
voire du rock est socialiste
sur l'amendement chez le groupe ump sur
l'amendement de madame demontès là je
vous rappelle que la commission a
défavorable le gouvernement défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront aux sénateurs un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
lutin bleu ceux qui souhaitent obtenir
un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
oui mais
demain
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos j'invite mesdames messieurs
secrétaire a procédé au dépouillement du
scrutin
ouais
le salon de ce jeu
je les connais
cinq ans et serait fonctionnel
g
voilà
c'est salé
à venir
m
sur le
voici le résultat du scrutin 75 sur
l'amendement 241 à l'article 33 nombre
de votants 338 le nombre de suffrages
exprimés
336 majorité des suffrages exprimés
169 pour l'adoption 153 contre 183 le
sénat n'a pas adopté
son flair ou pire un amendement en ce
sens est il ya des demandes de hausses
notables
sur l'amendement 1157 y at il des
demandes d'explications de vote il y en
a pas
je suis saisi d'une demande de souhaite
un public par le groupe ump vous retirer
alors on le retire et on va faire voter
sur 7
l'amendement jeu fait voter sur
l'amendement 1157 ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption vole bien levé
la main
non laissez nous le temps de compter
c'est tout pour l'instant nous vous
compte on on va voir après et ceux qui
sont contre
oui
face à pas
le l'amendement n'a pas n'est pas
adoptée sur la s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît on a compté alors et nous avons
compté oh bah écoutez ça suffit nous
avons compté nous avons compté or ça
suffit ça suffit
nous sommes sur l'amendement nous sommes
sur l'amendement 1213 c'est un avis
favorable du gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont favorables à
son amendement
à
combien ici l'amendement est à 2 heures
contre d'autres corps
contre s'il vous plaît contre contre
lever la main levé la main levé la main
60 à droite ipsos en tout cas combien je
vous salue
d
ok au 10 12 64
53 63
l'amendement est adopté
nous passons maintenant à deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement 1158 que défend même la
barre madame la présidente monsieur
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
vous avez pris la décision de mettre
dans cet article 33 relatifs aux
dispositions finales l'ensemble des
mesures de datation des diverses mesures
contenues dans ce projet cela vous a
permis de dissocier les mesures
annoncées de leur entrée en fait
effective en application l'effet
d'annoncé ce comté devez vous permettre
de masquer aussi un élément essentiel de
la mesure c'est particulièrement le cas
de la guinée à cat ainsi rédigé cet
alinéa ne pas dire grand chose
il précise que l'article 25 de ce projet
de loi ne s'appliquera qu'à compter du
1er janvier 2012 au plus tard
mais cet article 25 concernent le
chapiteau premier de ce projet qui
concerne un sujet particulièrement
sensible qui a été longuement débattue
dans cet hémicycle
ils étaient six qu'il était si question
de la pénibilité et plus
particulièrement de la prévention de la
pénibilité
je ne reviendrai pas ici sur tout ce qui
nous oppose aux différentes mesures de
ce projet sur cette même question mais
l'article 25 concernent la mise en place
du dossier médical en santé dus au
travail qui doit retracer les
informations relatives à l'état de santé
du travailleur aux expositions
auxquelles il a été soumis ainsi que les
avis et propositions du médecin du
travail
or l'écriture de cet alinéa dont nous
vous demandons la suppression précise
que ce dossier médical ne prendra en
compte que les expositions survenu à
compter de la date fixée par décret au
plus tard le 1er janvier 2012
ce faisant ce dossier médical n'aura pas
la mémoire du trajet professionnel des
salariés
il permet même de tirer un trait sur sur
le passé de ce salarié
cette disposition
mais pour le moins choquant ainsi même
si des expositions dangereuse passé ont
été reconnus reconnues elles
disparaîtront
aucune trace des situations difficiles
elles seront même réputés ne pas avoir
existé
on passe ainsi en pure perte et profit
toutes les expositions dangereuse
intervenue avant la date fixée par
décret
c'est inacceptable même si demain les
progrès de la science montre le lien
causal entre telle maladie est-elle
situation professionnelle il n'y aura
pas trace de cette dernière
il sera alors très difficile de prendre
en charge tous les salariés concernés
vous comprendrez donc neutre au talent
notre total désaccord avec cet alinéa
dont nous vous demandons la suppression
merci l'amendement 478 que défend voici
votre froid oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre avant de défendre
cet amendement très rapidement je
voudrais dire à nos collègues de la
majorité que j'ai trouvé tout à fait
discourtois le fait qu'ils essaient de
empêcher notre collègue et ami pierre
mauroy deux filières sont exposés pour
upe attendait pour une petite minute
pour une petite minute moi je dois vous
dire que pour que je dois vous dire que
je dois vous dire que mais c'est pas la
peine d'aboyer pourquoi vous hurlez je
vous ai pas dit de mal encore ou alors
vous vous sentez vraiment fautif je moi
je ne verrai pas objet d aucun
inconvénient
si monsieur enfin par a failli
m'excuseras de citer alors qu'il n'est
pas là mais si monsieur raffarin ancien
premier ministre voulait nous faire
savoir sa position et s'il considère que
la façon dont l'âme est là la réforme
est menée est bonne ou pas bonne ça ne
me dérangerait pas qu'ils dépassent
d'une minute son temps de parole alors
concernant concernant concernant
concernant l'article 30
concernant l'article 33
concernant l'article 33 monsieur le
rapporteur mais monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
notre amendement vous propose de
remplacer les mots intervenu par les
mots en cours ou prenant des faits je
pense que attendait la discussion que
nous avons eue cet après midi notamment
sur l'ami rente
il est bien évident que quand ce dossier
médical de santé va être quand la fiche
d'exposition va être très il est tout à
fait possible de prendre les expositions
en cours parce que nous ne savons pas ce
de ce que sera demain demain des
personnes exposées un certain nombre de
produits peuvent pouvoir faire valoir
des droits
avec des conditions d'exposition avec
des durées d'exposition qui seront
fixées à ce moment là ça peut être dans
dix ans et ne seront pas pris en compte
tels que vous avez rédigé cet alinéa ne
sont pas prêts à leur l exposition ils
le commenceront est exposé de fait à des
matières nocives que à partir du mois de
janvier 2012
donc moi je vous demande monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs monsieur le
ministre que l'on marque en cours ou
prenant effet ce ne sera pas très
compliqué pour le médecin du travail de
pouvoir vérifier que des personnes dans
l'entreprise voulait avant 2012 ont été
exposés à un certain nombre de risques
pendant une dizaine d'années 7 8 ans je
pense que ce serait une rédaction de bon
sens merci l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur ces deux
amendements
merci madame la présidente chers
collègues donc pour le premier
amendement le 1158 il est
malheureusement impossible aujourd'hui
de reconstituer on le sait les
expositions à des risques professionnels
et c'est tout l'enjeu
un des articles 25 et suivants du projet
de loi
il est donc nécessaire de fixer dès
maintenant une date d'entrée en vigueur
et la commission donne un avis
défavorable sur le 478 cet amendement
vise à étendre le contenu du dossier
médical aux expositions en cours ou
prenant effet à compter d'une date fixée
par décret cela pose bien sûr la
question d'un traçabilité sur le passé
qui l'a malheureusement aujourd'hui pas
de réponse pertinente donc avis
défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre c'est le même que celui du
rapporteur madame
et pour cause on a bien mesuré qu'il
fallait avoir une traçabilité pour le
passé et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il défavorables on a besoin de mesurer
merci monsieur le ministre je vais donc
fermé madame david oui madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre c'est quand même
assez grave ce que vous venez de nous
dire parce que ça veut dire finalement
l'article 25 qui a fait l'objet ici d'un
débat important qui concerne la
pénibilité des travailleurs et bien cet
article ne s'appliquera qu'à partir
d'une date fixée par décret et au plus
tard au 1er janvier 2012
mais qui va prendre en compte des
expositions intervenus du coup après
cette date
donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui tous
les travailleurs qui sont dans des
travaux pénibles ne seront pas pris dans
la pénibilité
donc ça veut dire que finalement vous
avez insisté pour définir cette idée de
la pénibilité mais tous les travailleurs
qui aujourd'hui sont dans des travaux
pénibles qui sont à l'âge de 56 57 ans
ben euh ils iront finalement jusqu'au 62
ans voire 67 ans puisque il va falloir
un certain temps il va falloir une
certaine durée d'exposition à ces
travaux pénibles et en plus tout à été
individualisées donc vous individualisé
tout mais là bizarrement vous
collectiviser la date pour la prise en
compte de la pénibilité
je trouve que c'est quand même très
grave pour la santé des travailleurs et
là encore quand vous nous dites que vous
faites une réforme juste qu'elle va
prendre en compte la santé des
travailleurs que vous êtes attaché à la
prévention des conditions de travail eh
bien vous avez des paroles et vous avez
des actes et les actes ne correspondent
pas à vos paroles
le seul ministre donc je suis désolé de
vous dire que véritablement c'est une
escroquerie envers les milliers
millions de travailleurs qui aujourd'hui
travaillent dans des conditions de
pénibilité avérée mais que vous ne
reconnaîtrez pas parce que la prise en
compte de cette pénibilité sera au plus
tard le 1er janvier 2012 en tout cas
renvoyer à un décret véritablement c'est
pas du tout honnête c'est pas du tout
juste pour tous les travailleurs qui
aujourd'hui sont dans les travaux
pénibles
voilà pour les discussions d'hier soir
dans l'hémicycle tout de suite nous
rejoignons l'hémicycle en direct pour
les discussions de ce matin les
sénateurs reprennent sur un amendement
de philippe dominati qui porte sur
l'harmonisation des règles de calcul des
pensions et à 12h45 ne manquez pas le
point retraites présenté par pierre
henri gergonne avec un invité et les
meilleurs moments de la séance 137 11 du
code de la sécurité sociale actes et
donner du dépôt de ce document il a été
transmis à la commission des affaires
sociales il sera disponible au bureau de
la distribution l'ordre du jour appelle
la suite de la discussion du projet de
loi adopté par l'assemblée nationale
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée portant réforme des retraites
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus un article additionnel
avant le titre premier monsieur courtois
vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre